When you're with people
who are well versed to enjoy.
And that is the time you increase.
So, number one, references
give authenticity to your speech.
A person who doubts can check you.
Besides checking, it reconfirms.
Okay, fine.
You heard. Not that I doubt the speaker.
He said that he quoted a verse of the
Quran,
"Oh, you Muslims are the best of people
who work for mankind."
Now, everyone doesn't know.
You can note down.
So, if you wrote the reference to go
back home, it's easier. To write the
full verse and the translation is more
difficult rather than to write
3:110.
3:110 is Surah Al Imran chapter 3 verse
110.
While writing notes 3:110, then you go
home and you get the full verse.
Imagine if you have to write down 2:282.
What is 2:282?
Longest verse, sorry.
That's the longest verse in the Quran.
Dealing with?
That's the
Ayah Al Ladheena
debt. Sorry? It's talking about debt.
Talking about? Debt.
Close to it, but anyway, the longest
verse of the Quran, part of the longest
Surah of the Quran, talking about two
witnesses when you get into a financial
transaction.
Take two witnesses. If you can't find
two men,
take one man and two women. It's the
longest verse.
Now, imagine you have to note down that
verse, it will take you all long. 2:282.
Easy go home and check up. Oh, no, you
have laptop.
So, besides giving authenticity, besides
proving yourself you're right, it helps
a person to use your lecture points
also.
So, if you have to note the salient
points of a lecture with references,
only type two, type two, type two
reference
310, 303,
16:125,
41:33.
A small piece of paper you note down,
the full lecture, majority can be
reproduced.
So, that means you want your lecture to
be effective,
beneficial for you, beneficial for the
audience, even beneficial for your
enemies.
Beneficial why?
They get Hidayah.
And I know many of the people I am going
to tell who Allah give Hidayah
through my lectures, one of the reasons
was we did not believe you initially.
Other people give tall stories, he's
giving many tall stories, you know.
Think that.
And when they say that is when they turn
and check.
And even
you will find on the YouTube
there are many criticisms, enemies
of people
who do good work.
And if I may have to say, "Oh, he just
says things out of context. He says
things which don't exist.
He just bluffs."
Now, he's trying to criticize me. But
someone wants to check, okay, let's see
whether Zakir really bluffs. And then
when they come to check and they know
he's not bluffing, that means they will
say these people are criticizing a man
of truth.
Even the enemies
they respect you. And that was
I mean, we are nowhere close, the best
example is Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam
that even the enemies called him
Al-Amin,
the trustworthy, the truthful. So, as a
da'ee,
you cannot even lie if it is against
you.
So, references give authenticity, they
give power, give confidence to the
person listening to you.
It reconfirms.
It has various benefits and more we will
discuss during the course
of the training program.
Now,
what is the technique?
What is the most important
technique for giving references?
3:16.
Alhamdulillah. Master key.
3:16. Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. Allah forsakes you, who is there
that can help you? Let the believers put
their trust in Allah.
Take it for granted, any good work in
the world that you can do,
you put 3:16, it will fit.
Many other verses are also applicable,
but 3:16 is the master key
for any difficulty, any difficulty,
anything which is good work. If it is
difficult for you, the master key is
3:16. Not only in dawah,
in your business also.
Not only in giving references, in doing
calculation in your accounts also.
Anything on this earth
if it's good and if it's difficult for
you, your master key is Allah.
How many people here have done MBA?
Anyone has done MBA?
Masters in business administration or
bachelors in business administration?
No one?
No one has done administration here?
Masters, bachelors. Many a time Who have
done?
Oh, hotel hotel management. Give it to
the hotelier.
Masha Allah. If from LA, it's a very
famous city, the casino. Alhamdulillah.
Coming from dark to the light. I did
hotel   business
management. So, expertise in hotel with
a lot of courses of business management.
Have you learned any technique of
memory?
Uh
>> Normally, if you do BBA or MBA, they
teach you techniques of memory.
Memorization, no. Do you know what's
mapping?
No. Do you know what's triangle? No.
Anyone knows what's mapping?
Mapping.
Not the world map of India or
China.
Who knows mapping? See, when I use some
knowledge,
if it's that simple as a map, everyone
so you know you raise your hand.
If you know you raise or if you're
confident.
100% sure or maybe 90% sure, but just
for trying then
Yes, brother Imran. What is mapping?
Connecting with some kind of a story so
that you can relate it backwards.
Connecting some kind of a story related
backwards.
To remember anything, you create a map
in your head. For example,
I have to remember about the verses. So,
I join a map uh another point and I make
a map in my head. So, I remember how
many points are there for that
particular topic. I use a map in my
head.
He told small percentage, he told a
little bit small.
See, knowing is something else and
explaining is something else.
Drawing a map in my head, yes.
Brother
I
Sorry, Zakir I don't know what is
mapping. Don't know then forget it. Give
it to somebody. Don't waste your time.
See, now I'm mapping in my mind. This
person is trying fluke mar
chakka lag gaya. Don't waste it because
we are doing a course. If you know
Not that always you have to be 100%
correct, but if you know you know, don't
guess.
Guessing then the whole program will go
33 days will take 63 days.
And then you'll realize after some time
you will raise your hand I don't ask
you. You raise your hand I don't ask
you. Why? My memory tells me this person
is fluke. Then fluke always heads or
tails the chances you'll be right is
chances you'll be right is
50%. So, why not try?
Yes, no, why? Don't know.
Mapping is not so mapping.
If it's memory and mapping then mapping
and memory, yes. So, you let the story
go backwards.
No head, no tail.
Brother Ash little bit correct.
Not able to explain it. You know, now
what do you do? You take mapping,
talking about memory, use your
intelligence, join it and give the
answer.
In the examination you have to write
something so it's good in examination.
But if there's negative no negative
marking in the top examination if you
write objective give wrong negative
marks. Otherwise give wrong no loss no
positive if you give right one mark. So,
why not try?
10% to lag gaya. Please don't do that.
Because then what will happen? Even
tomorrow if you really know the answer I
will not ask you also.
So, if you know you raise your hand
otherwise
After I GIVE THE ANSWER YES YES I KNEW
THIS I didn't raise my hand. This is all
fluke.
A die should not talk about fluke.
Because why? If you give certain things
when you start giving like that answers,
then the impression comes, "Ah, this
fellow is just trying luck."
Being smart is good. Being extra smart
is not good.
You understand now? So, once okay, twice
okay. So, if you're a liar, you keep on
giving such
in the question and answer, and someone
asks you and you give vague answers, the
person who is an expert will think this
person is bluffing.
And then you realize this speaker is a
bluff master.
You understand?
So, please, if you know it, you know it,
or you don't know it. Not that you
always have to be right.
If I say guess, then you can put up your
hand and try all your guesses. Who knows
it? If you know, you raise your hand.
Otherwise,
you understand?
Don't try and guess.
In guesses, you may be right, but that's
fluke.
Is it clear?
You know it?
Or you don't know it.
If I say guess, then you can everyone
can raise your hand and guess whether
you're right 5% and 10%. Mapping is a
specialized technique
of memory.
Mapping means map has to be there.
If you say something,
and whether it's a little bit correct or
shiver to a little.
They say, "Okay, you
tell me 10 words."
Any word.
What does Sugimoto tell a word?
Any word? Any word you can think of.
Map.
Map. Farid, tell a word. Huh?
Run. Run.
Read. Read.
Write. Write.
So, what?
Map.
Run.
Read. Write. So, you create a story.
When he says, "Okay, sweet." He creates,
"Okay, map is here." Then you can create
the story the way you want.
He said, "Map." Okay, you create. You
can create anything. Map of the world,
map this, it's on the floor. He says,
"Read." He says, "Run."
Run, read, write."
So, map one man running, you can have
woman running, Islamic you know write.
But, in this technique we have a woman
running on the map.
A woman running on the ground.
A woman running in athletic field. You
create what you want.
Write. Okay, write it on the desk, write
it on the wall, write it on the
blackboard. You create.
Write, read.
Then you give a number, 1 2 3, then you
have either on the map someone is
running
or someone writing or you create the
picture and the picture to remember
becomes easier as we discussed.
So, you create a story.
You map it the way you want. Your
mapping will differ from my mapping,
will differ from his mapping. It doesn't
make a difference.
Even if it's unrealistic,
no problem, you create
a map
in your mind.
Allah.
Allah,
ya
Rabbi, ya Allah.